the xbox series x the playstation 5 and
of course the pc now what do all these
three have in common that they can
output at 4k 120 hertz the only problem
is that most monitors out there lack the
hdmi 2.1 support that all these consoles
need so most of us console gamers are
left with 4k 60hz for our 4k tvs which
isn't a bad thing by all means but again
the problem here is most of these tvs
and monitors will be very expensive take
the lg c1 tv for instance it's 4k it has
oled and it can output 120 hertz but
it's super expensive and on top of that
if you already own a 4k tv is it worth
the upgrade and not to mention investing
in the space to house their 48-inch tv
so when asus reached out to us and asked
if we would like to review their newest
large size gaming monitor i mean
of course i had to say why the hell not
so boy am i excited to show you this
gaming display you guys know what to do
well the thing
this video is brought to you by secret
lab now here at geek culture we do love
our secret lab chairs we use it for work
we use it for gaming and pretty much
everything that we do what we like about
the chess is that secret lab offers
different sizes from the omega to the
titan and the titan xl you can also
customize the material with prime 2.0 pu
leather and their super plush fabric
soft weave not only that they've got
designs of all your favorite esports
teams and special editions themed after
league of legends world of warcraft dc
batman and even game of thrones
so there's definitely a chair for you so
do check out secret lab link in the
description below what's up everybody
zaki here from geek culture bringing you
another fantastic video this time we'll
be showing you this bad boy
this is the asus rog strix xg43uq
very long winded not sure what's up with
tech these days but
there it is it's a large size gaming
display as you can tell it's funny
when sleep that's how you wake things up
it's a large size gaming display and
you're probably wondering to yourself
boy zacky that's that's huge
and as a matter of fact it is i mean
asus dubs this as the large size gaming
display but it's a small tv no it's
still gaming display
but it is still tv with a display this
huge it took two of our humble
colleagues to actually prop this up on
the table just just so you know you need
two people to help you install this as
long as you get it out of the box
properly on the table you're pretty much
good to go and since we're talking about
the unboxing process we might also let
you know what's in the box of course you
got the display you do have a remote
control
batteries does not come included and it
takes two
aaa batteries on top of that you do get
some extra cables this includes the usb
a to usb b cable which helps to get
extended support with the usb ports at
the back you also do get a high speed
hdmi cable 2.1 of course you can connect
it to either your computer or to your
playstation 5 or xml series x as well as
a display port 1.4 cable and of course
an aura sync logo projector that you can
mount on the back of your monitor so you
can have a nice little rg logo that you
can put in rgb but we'll talk about that
later of course you do get the power
brick and the slew of power adapters
depending on your region as far as
documentation goes you got your quick
installation guide you got your warranty
card got your rog stickers
if you're a fan of that and this is
pretty neat you do get a calibration
report from the manufacturers themselves
you know it kind of tells you
how good this monitor is in terms of
like color accuracy and stuff like that
i won't get into detail about it but if
you do want to take a look i'm just
gonna pop it in the screen right now
feel free to pause that
and yeah so with that out of the way
let's go into the design and build now
this is a 43 inch display it's huge and
it's pretty hefty too and for someone
who has gone from a 27 inch monitor to a
43 inch monitor i mean this takes the
kick for scale and with a 60 inch table
it's
it takes up 80 percent of the length of
the table already now if you want to
have a second monitor might not be
feasible because the 43-inch large
display
is is pretty overwhelming by itself now
it doesn't come with visa mounts so you
have to use it on the stand itself you
could find ways to mount it on a wall or
have a desk arm mounted on it but from
what we know asus doesn't provide a
solution for you so bear that in mind
now don't expect slim bezels just like a
tv wood i mean there are some bezels but
i'm not too perturbed by it oh what a
fancy wood yeah not much going on in
front of the monitor of course you got
the nice rog logo here i really do love
the stands one thing about the stance is
first of all it's minimal it's a nice
unique design it's made out of solid
metal and at the bottom you have nice
rubberized circular feet that prevents
you from scratching your table and we
have a wood finish on top of this table
does already have a few scratches kind
of eliminates the
scratching on the table nobody likes
that nobody wants that now this display
stand comes with a negative 5 degree to
10 degree tilt there's no civil action
here
for me personally
this works fine but if you have an
l-shaped table and you kind of want to
need some swivel action to just
reposition how you want your display to
be
you know it might not be the monitor for
you so do take note of that as well so
moving on to the back of the display
this is where it gets interesting now
of course in rog fashion
this is fully decked out in white with
some futuristic little textures they
make it pretty awesome
now
of course this chassis is made out of
plastic and that's to just keep things a
little bit lighter for you to carry
now you get a lot of very cool
interesting textures here with the vents
being in a little futuristic design
you've got a very
big rg logo motif over here and a few
ventilation points as well now if i push
this to the side a little bit very risky
okay gonna give asus a little bit of a
heart attack there now of course you can
see a little bit more on the display
stand over here
solid metal two screws on each side it
goes into the back panel and this is
ready to take on world war three all
right this is pretty much indestructible
in terms of design and build now on the
left side of the back panel here this is
where you will find your connectivity
ports now there's two zones as i would
call it the first zone let's call it
zone b is where you'll find the audio
line in your headphone jack two usb 3.0
ports
a usb b port on top of that you get two
hdmi 2.0 ports on the side here as well
now if you look closely
you can pry this out
and in zone a
you do get your hdmi 2.1 ports you get
the displayport 1.4
you get the aura sync projector
thing that i'll show you later and of
course your power adapter port what i
love about it is that asus has really
thought about the design how you connect
your cables so in that sense
you can have cables running into here
down through this canal and then you
have cable management clips at the side
here to just keep things very neat
because they know that you're gonna
mount this probably on your desk
you might not be facing a wall people
are gonna see the back of this monitor
so to keep things very neat all you need
to do is to just you know
and it's all neat now at the side here
you get four neat buttons and a little
joystick
with the four buttons
in a very
cool design
aesthetic to it and i think it also
helps with ergonomics because it
alternates in different directions and
on top of that it also has some texture
to it so you can kind of feel if you're
reaching out the back you know like what
button is what and a mini joystick helps
you out with navigation and control over
there you don't necessarily have to
reach at the back because you do get a
remote control and the remote control is
good enough for what you need to do
power you can change the source you can
navigate through the dials here cancel
button quick shortcuts and the volume
now what i wish they had implemented
into this control is just a mute button
here at the office we need to
communicate and i mean
this monitor can be pretty loud so
having a nice mute button for a shortcut
would be good especially when you're
gaming on a console so
one thing to note asus alright now that
being said what i have here is the aura
sync projector and you know you can't
really do much
with this i thought it was a webcam at
first by the way and what it does is
that it has a mounting point at the back
of the words right here and it will just
project down the asus logo in any of
your rgb
colors that you like or you can cycle
through them if you want to anyway this
is like the most now i don't want to
slam asus but
honestly what were they thinking
first of all the projection ain't that
great it does not do much for me and
even though this monitor is aura sync
capable that's the only rgb thing you're
gonna get out of it now if it was like
the asus pg-34 if i'm not wrong where
the motif here was rgb hey like that
would have made sense but this thing
this you know just just keep it aside
man asus come on man i think you guys
could do way better so when it comes to
pc performance i mean i've really got no
complaints here when it comes to reading
of text watching movies video editing
photoshop it does it and it does it well
now of course when it comes to text when
you start scrolling it does have a
little bit of that ghosting which fuzzes
the eyes a little bit you know i didn't
have too much expectations when it comes
to a va panel this is a gaming display
you know of course i wish this was an
ips display just for that color accuracy
and that vibrancy you really want to get
when it comes to video editing in
photoshop but other than that it works
now if there's one thing to nitpick
about is the on-screen display menu the
thing is when it comes to pc whether
it's displayport and hdmi 2.1 is that
most of the features here seems like
it's more catered to the consoles
instead when we come up to the on-screen
display menu here we realize that a lot
of the gaming features such as
overclocking el mb sync game visual and
shadow boost they are grayed out we
can't select them we can't do anything
so of that when it comes to the image
and color settings if you were to
customize it you don't have a lot of
options there either in terms of image
we can change the hdr max brightness the
hdr and the dynamic dimming you can't
change anything about the color which
for designers and video editors like
myself
changing the color and to redo the
calibration to our lighting settings
would help a lot and this is not
available it is kind of sad i don't know
that ain't much would i like to see more
customization on that of course i would
but going into gaming on this monitor it
works really really well any game you
want to put into this monitor it's going
to run well other than that though i
really got nothing to complain about
there really isn't much to complain when
it comes to the game quality because
that all depends on your settings anyway
but this display when gaming at hdr and
hdl 1000 is
really something else this monitor can
do it now the cool thing is because this
is a gaming monitor asus has given you
some unique tools to help you amplify
your gaming experience it's also known
as game plus
and the cool and unique thing about it
is that it allows you to actually have a
few things crosshair timer your fps
counter display alignment and sniper
mode unfortunately sniper mode
is only available
when you're playing on the console it
kind of sucks but essentially what
sniper mode does is that it gives you a
little bit of a box in the center of the
screen that magnifies and you can
actually change the magnification anyway
it's it's it's pretty cool because it
really helps a lot and when you're
playing battlefield as a sniper it just
gives you a little bit more
zoom zoom you know zoom zoom my favorite
one obviously it's it's a little bit of
a cheat i mean you won't get this when
you're playing like competitively you'll
probably be banned
but
here game plus you have a crosshair mode
which you can add either red dot green
dot or just different types of
crosshairs especially when you play
a lot of games that don't have crosses
in them maybe if you play hardcore call
of duty or escape from tarkov oh man i
love this i love this so much now as far
as console gaming which is the main
priority for this display here it runs
well at 120 hertz we're talking about
games such as call of duty black ops
cold war gears of war destiny 2 rainbow
six siege those games run phenomenal and
because this monitor does have hdr 1000
it's it's best played with that superb
and speaking about superb the order
quality is actually pretty decent as
well i mean look
monitors generally don't come with good
quality sound but because this is
technically almost a tv like experience
sound is pretty good and you know audio
is good when you play it loud and this
monitor can go loud
[Music]
um
[Music]
i mean you don't have dolby atmos or
anything like that where you can hear
everything around you everybody else
would say we would recommend you getting
a samba or set of headphones for that
but if you want something that is just
really plug and play and just enjoy it
this set of speakers on this display
would do the job fine so final thoughts
who is this monitor for and is it worth
the price for its price point at
2099 singapore dollars asus has shown
that you don't need a big ass tv
at
exorbitant price tags to enjoy console
gaming 120 hertz if you're looking at
this as an everyday monitor to do all
your documentation software watch movies
hey this monitor is also great for doing
that in terms of color accuracy and the
richness of colors it's pretty decent
for va panel now it's not going to be
oled because that's gonna be too
expensive it could have been an ips
display for that matter just to have a
little bit more richness and vibrancy
from that panel we will still start to
see more monitors like this or even
smaller ones with the hdmi 2.1 port
being able to output it at 4k 120 hertz
there's still some conflict between that
because the thing is we are not sure
that every game out there or future
games for that matter will have that 4k
120 hertz option and it's not really 4k
as well talking about super sampling and
things like that i won't go i won't bore
you with damn detail so definitely
definitely bang for your buck when it
comes to its price point so i will
personally say that i do recommend this
monitor but what you're getting here is
performance price and quality it's truly
a hard deal to pass so we hope you
enjoyed this in-depth review if you did
do give us a like and consider
subscribing it helps out the channel and
do leave your comments down below if
you're gonna get this monitor as well
until then stay safe take care and we
chat to you soon see you guys
[Music]
you